[Music]
so what's it like being in l.a
you i like l.a do you like l.a i like la
very very much
yeah i was here in the 80s you lived
here back in the 80s this is a good
area for us because we are both uh tall
very pale irishmen yes
and i don't know about you but when i
said that i was moving out to los
angeles
i got mostly looks of concern from
people
were people worried for you when you
said i'm going out to l.a i did
because of the sun yes yes that's what i
mean yeah yeah we're irish we burn up
yeah how fast do you burn fast yeah
i i i can get i can look drunk red in
the face in about
three minutes do you wear a big i wear a
big ladies hat when i walk around i just
wear number 60.
just smear it all over number 60. yeah
i've got 160
actually it fires light back at the sun
but you know when i was when i was 16
uh-huh and back home in northern ireland
i used to lie on top of our cool house
roof
smear oil that you fry chips in
all over my face in order to get the sun
really that's uh did you when did you
burst into flames when did that happen
i got i got intense yeah it got very
intense i have a question for you which
is
i think you you said it's been 25 years
you've been spending a lot of time in
l.a
but you still have that terrific irish
accent
yeah yes you do it's just very slight
but has it gone away
at all or is this pretty much how you
grew up speaking no
if okay here's how i grew up speaking
how you doing conan is
all right aaron's all right hi i'm i'm
liam neeson i
i'm from baltimore kenya and i talk like
this
so you had food in your mouth
that's how it sounds but listen
seriously how serious
how close does that sound to the
kentucky accent where they talk like
that and i'm talking like this
you know what i mean it's very similar
very very similar well you know what's
interesting is that
uh i grew up uh right outside boston and
we had these neighbors
the murphy brothers and i'd my dad would
go and tell me to go show you
they were yes they were these two
gentlemen from ireland and they had the
caps
and people always think of in the united
states they say oh the irish accent
and they do the lucky charms oh be
caution bigora
but the real irish accent these guys i'd
have to go out and shovel snow and these
guys would be shoveling snow next to me
and i'd say oh you know
uh miss uh murphy brothers it sure is a
lot of snow they'd be like
i could not understand a word they were
saying